cette année la galette aussi était au
caramel à caramel paris mais avec un cas
on en a fait une marque de fabrique avec
une certaine saveur de madeleine de
proust souvenirs d'enfance de ma
normandie natale des petits plats de ma
mère de mes grands-parents des odeurs
qui me reviennent voilà tout était très
agressif et pour moi ça faisait du sens
de créer des pâtisseries au dehors de ce
créneau
c'est un rêve d'enfant j'ai toujours
voulu faire en fait démarré très tôt
c'était un instrument grand temps et
toujours été un rêve ensuite ma carrière
professionnelle a fait que j'ai pris mon
temps j'ai réfléchi longtemps
et puis et puis voilà je me suis décidé
cette année en quart et enrobés de
chocolat ou en pâtisserie le caramel est
décliné sous toutes ses formes
imaginez en équipe nicholas lewin lance
son atelier sur lui en courant février
la boutique elle sur paris a ouvert une
semaine avant les fêtes de noël
j'habite petit but en cours depuis cinq
ans et pour moi c'était c'était une
belle c'était un moyen facile de pouvoir
allier ma vie professionnelle et ma vie
privée je ne voyais pas pour démarrer
ouvrir une pâtisserie à vue en cours
donc l'idée c'était vraiment essayer
d'avoir une ancienne parisienne caramel
paris s'est pour le moment une équipe
d'une dizaine de personnes dont sept à
l'atelier de guyancourt
après les bûches et les galettes le
caramel se testera en amoureux lors de
la saint valentin